[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de paf
nous allons essayer peut-être de voyage
et un petit peu de voir ce qui se passe
aussi à l'étranger notamment aux états
unis
comment se gèrent la crise du virus aux
états unis et puis quelle est leur effet
à cette crise au fond sur la mentalité
peut-être sur le rêve américain
et puis évidemment on parlera peut-être
aussi de lui déconfite mans et de la
pyrrhus ici aussi en france alors pour
en parler lorie kane dont bonjour
bonjour vous êtes maître de conférences
à l'université de versailles saint
quentin vous êtes spécialiste de la
civilisation
l'ophone et vous avez publié plusieurs
ouvrages les derniers la place
historique des états unis sédition
autrement et puis la fin du rêve
américain
chez odile jacob suivi mclaughlin
bonjour vous êtes vous êtes responsable
des relations institutionnelles de
l'institut du think tank think tank
nouvelle génération s'appelle sapiens et
vous êtes franco-américaine père
américain de mère française ont bravé
les généalogies mais enfin et et vous
votez notamment aux etats-unis 1
tout à fait je vote aux états unis par
le vote à new york ce qui ne l'a pas
fait à new york à new york
quoi qu'il arrive les démocrates gagnent
donc je vote pour faire mon devoir mais
c'est pas d'une très grande utilité
observé gina bonjour vous êtes maître de
conférences à l'université de hong hong
et à sciences po et florence mercadé
choqué bonjour oui bonjour patrice
avocate au barreau de versailles et vous
avez étudié aux états unis aussi
oui carrément
et là on a aussi des des garçons 12e
jean baptiste duclair bonjour patrice ou
à bien vous êtes mal de conférences à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
c'était notamment en droit public et
jean charles lajoie ni vous êtes éditeur
bonjour vous êtes de ceux qui se
réjouissent évidemment de la réouverture
des librairies absolument seul même si
même si le livre aux crises et des
démissions et réalisé par romain respini
et voilà alors on va parler d'abord
d'aider de des états unis peut-être
avant de parler de la gestion de la
crise de trump des élections qui se
profilent
peut-être est-ce que les auront lieu
c'est une question qui se pose aussi
peut-être dans un état d'esprit
américain et c'est peut-être vrai
rouleau rekem dont je vais me tourner
qu'elle a été au fond l'effet de
l'arrivée de ce virus c'est quand même
un peuple qui après à dominer la nature
et tout d'un coup il ya ce retour en
force de la nature comment ça a été
vécue alors c'est très difficile de
généraliser puis retour en force de la
nature on l'a régulièrement à chaque
fois qu'il ya une tornade ou ce genre de
choses qui font l'actualité et c'est
très très fréquent de toute façon donc
la nature se rappelle au bon souvenir
des américains de manière très fréquente
mais pas forcément de cette façon là que
là au niveau de la santé publique bon ça
reste un gros sujet de manioc des
épidémies c'est quand même plus rares
donc on a une manifestation qui est
assez rare de quelque chose qui est
assez commun le retour de la nature
ça c'est un paradoxe aux états unis
justement parce qu'il ya ce côté vous
vous rappeliez qui est le côté les
pionniers qui ont domestiqué
là la nature pour construire leur pays
mais tout ça s'inscrit dans un contexte
notamment politique où la question de la
santé avant la pandémie était déjà la
première question dans les priorités des
américains en tout cas en général c'est
moins vrai pour les républicains que
pour les démocrates bien sûr mais ça
s'inscrit dans quelque chose qui est pas
absolument hors de propos c'est à dire
que la question numéro 1 c'était pas le
terrorisme ou etc
c'était déjà la question de la santé
donc on a
une sorte de pertinence de la crise dans
les préoccupations des américains déjà
c'est vrai que l'un des grands débats de
l'élection de 2016 ça a été ça a été au
four le à le projet d'obama le caire
d'obama contre lequel s'étaient élevées
notamment fin c'était c'était un des
grands le facteur dès qu'on dépasse la
dose de cette campagne en tout cas oui
c'est vrai et est une idée question qui
se prolonge en fait cette année c'est
savoir s'il faut le supprimer ou
l'amendé de façon suffisante pour qu'il
soit complètement dénaturé comme le
veulent les républicains ou l'étendre
voileux l'améliorer comme le veulent les
démocrates de manière assez assez
diverses puisqu'on a eu un nombre de
candidats record avec un nombre de
projets très différents en fonction de
si on parle de by day nous si on parle
de sanders donc la question de la santé
est au coeur la question de l'obamacare
est au coeur des questions de santé et
la pandémie arrive donc dans ce contexte
où on est vraiment très préoccupé par
les inégalités la couverture et et tout
c'est toutes ces questions en fait
qu'ils sont liés directement à la santé
et un directement aux questions
d'inégalité
ce fait back log in justement de cette
rupture le débat sur la santé c'est une
très grande préoccupation forte des
américains je trouve qu aux etats unis
là on n'y pense pas de la même façon
c'est-à-dire que pour nous en france
toutes les cours soit en termes de santé
c'est un acquis on est habitués mais
bizarrement aux états unis lorsqu'on a
des candidats qui propose d'avoir
également une sécurité sociale des ailes
ils sont jamais élus ont donc c'est
étonnant on est quand même plus basé aux
états unis sont une espèce de l'économie
de marché un peu plus brutale qu en
france et même en théorie les gens
disent pas ce serait bien la sécurité
sociale en fait ils fonctionnent pas il
ne fonctionne pas de cette façon là
c'est les heures et les sauces et aussi
les skis il semble peut-être pas bon
oui c'est aussi parce que souvent ils
sont couverts de manière très
satisfaisante par leur entreprise
donc il y en a en fait ceux qui sont
déjà couverts par leurs entreprises
n'ont pas envie que l'état vienne se
mêler de ceux de ce dossier parce que
ils ont la vision d'un état qui sait pas
faire ou qui complique équipe
bureaucratise à outrance et qui risquent
de aussi d'aller dans leur vie privée
une espèce de big brother quoi et donc
ils n'ont pas envie de ça parce qu'ils
sont déjà couverts de manière tout à
fait satisfaisante ce qui en fait aurait
besoin d'une douche à dire un gérant ce
n'est pas vraiment le terme et d'une
intervention de l'état dans ces
questions là sont soit de toute façon
déjà couvert par un certain nombre de
programmes qui existent en faut quand
même le dire soit vote finalement assez
peu et donc ne font pas la différence
car on a aussi un gros problème qui est
la question de la mobilisation et la
mobilisation est très différenciée en
fonction des groupes et de leurs
intérêts
oui est ce qu'il ya des différences
entre les états où est-ce que ça c'est
vraiment une décision sur sur le caire
qui s'impose à la totalité des états ce
qu'il peut y avoir des dix ans et avec
des états qui mettent en place des
dispositifs
c'est particulièrement visible sur des
questions comme l'avortement et la
pellerine product is right
ça c'est particulièrement visible mais
globalement en fait ça va dépendre de
l'aspect qu'on prend en considération il
ya des choses qui sont gérés par le
niveau fédéral il ya des choses qui sont
gérés au niveau des états il ya des
choses qui sont complètement privatiser
sachs ont géré au niveau de la relation
entre l'employé et l'employeur
donc ça va dépendre en fait alors on va
parler aussi de la gestion de deux de la
caisse du virus notamment et je vais
avoir l'opinion par exemple de charlène
où jean baptiste où jean charles est ce
que vous avez été surpris de la façon
dont seront ses conférences quotidiennes
comment il prend à bras le corps ce
problème en disant souvent n'importe
quoi on va y revenir mais est ce que ça
vous a surpris par rapport notamment la
communication du gouvernement français
non moi je crois pas qu'il y a de
surprise dans sa gestion du virus par
donald trump parce que donald trump
grimpe au final c'est à dire qu'on a on
a eu avec lui l'exemple de ce qu'on a pu
appeler l' expression populiste du début
sont à retrouver c'est quand même à
savoir la faye qui nous le sentiment
complotistes l'envoi des relations
internationales et la domination par un
organisme extérieur et et je crois que
justement cette manière d'occuper le
terrain c'est vraiment partie de sa
manière de faire de la politique c'est à
dire de personnaliser les débats et
d'essayer de ramener cette gestion à son
propre bilan alors ça ajustement des
effets pervers dans le sens où ça joue
en faveur de la réassurance dans un
premier temps mais où ça fait aussi
beaucoup lui conter si toutefois les
américains ne le suivent pas en masques
et je pense que ce qui est en panne et
c'est que
on va le juger sur cette omniprésence et
que c'est finalement la rançon de sa
manière de gérer cette crise ce qui
m'étonne un peu c'est la façon dont on
traite depuis la france qui se passe aux
états-unis en j'allais dire presque en
manipulant un peu les chiffres on a
l'impression qu'on se venge un peu parce
que comme personne n'aime trump ici et
qu'il ya quand même toujours un
sentiment anti américain si les français
que moi je m'explique pas trop mais bon
et alors du coup on se réjouit presque
ont dit vous avez vu il ya 80 mille
morts il ya beaucoup plus de morts aux
etats unis qu'en france
ben non hélas on est toujours en france
largement devant les etats unis en
nombre de morts et c'est cette drôle de
comptabilité qui met pas cette peine de
mort par l'habitant mais bien sûr mais
je pense que les chiffres de new york
sont assez assez grave et assez forts
notamment
non messieurs super du tout en train de
dire qu'il n'ya pas de maladies là bas
je suis je ne sais pas du tout
je trouve que c'est l'attitude française
on al'impression vraiment que le sait le
grand satan quoi alors il faut tout
arrêter quelque chose arrive des états
unis interdit vous avez vu toutes façons
c'est nul tout à son aise en plus de
mort toute façon c'est tout ce qu'ils
font c'est pas bien financer ce manque
de nuances sur l'appréciation des
américains est pour le moins troublante
surtout alors cela dit c'est pas sympa
les français ou c'est pas les européens
qui tue mais cette fois c'est barack
obama qui parle dans la gestion de deux
par 30 delà de l'accueil d'un des hearts
désastre chaotique sans précédent et
c'est sur times square 7 cette horloge
de la mort qui compte alors ça c'est
assez spectaculaire qui comptent les
morts les mooradian est-ce que le week
end où est-ce que vous avez été vous
surpris par cette façon de gérer la
crise on a l'impression de dire que
plusieurs étapes ans dans la gestion de
la crise par train c'est d'abord une
sorte de déni et puis ensuite d'une
prise en compte
il ya eu des revirements on a eu notre
lot de revirements chez nous quand on me
disait qu'il fallait sortir dans les
théâtres depuis deux jours après on
ferme les écoles parce que attention cet
affreux qu'il faut surtout pas aller sur
les plages tout seul
risque de contaminer de mouettes on a eu
un certain nombre de revirements dans
notre gestion de la crise mais c'est
vrai que alors pour revenir ce que
disait en charlène le mot clé dans la
compréhension de trump c'est le
narcissisme trump c'est un personnage de
télé réalité donc il a fait de la télé
réalité à part qu'il est président bon
il fait président en fait c'est son rôle
en ce moment il fait le président après
il fera autre chose mais il a fait des
années de télé réalité dont il a besoin
de sentir qu'il est au coeur de
l'événement et c'est pour ça qu'ils
racontent n'importe quoi jusqu'à parler
de raï a pas dit que j'allais boire de
l'eau de javel mais peut pas me demander
si ça aussi c'est un truc qu'on a un
petit peu monté en épingle
mais si l'eau de javel pouvait pas les
infections ne pouvait pas et des décès
en fait il dit des trucs parce qu'il
faut qu'ils occupent le terrain donc de
ce point de vue là c'est pas du tout
c'est pas du tout surprenant le fait de
transformer c'est la gestion de la crise
en événements télé de 2,2 presque
continue c'est pareil c'est que tu as
quelque chose qui était très très bien
mais ce qui est très narcissique en fait
avant d'être trump tient tous points de
vue là c'est pas du tout surprenant et
les revirements ont pas c'est aussi
parce que c'est là pour servir ses
intérêts là la grande obsession du
moment c'est de réouvrir l'économie
parce qu'il sait qu'il a complètement
foiré la jirs la gestion du duc au vide
pas de la copie pas mais voilà et donc
en fait son seul salut c'est la santé
économique à ce qu'il parte du principe
et ça c'est quelque chose qui est très
vrai en politique une offense à dire
qu'une semaine une éternité en politique
avec twitter qui change complètement
notre rapport au temps le rapport des
journalistes et des politiques autant 24
heures c'est une éternité en politique
et donc novembre à des années lumières
de maintenant et donc le raisonnement de
l'électeur la ya beaucoup d'électeurs
qui vont voter avant novembre du vote
anticipé etc
mais quand on part du principe que
disons la deuxième partie de deuxième
moitié d'octobre
à quoi vont penser les gens qui vont
voter est-ce qu'ils vont penser à la
gestion
par trump de l'épidémie en février mars
où est-ce qu'ils vont penser à la santé
économique des quinze derniers jours
finalement et donc c'est ça son pari
qu'un pari extrêmement risqué c'est
quelqu'un qui fait du casino train peint
donc voilà c'est las vegas son pari
c'est que l'économie sera en ordre de
bataille
disons mi octobre et que ça va jouer en
sa faveur et que finalement ce sera plus
important parce que ça c'est aussi
attesté par l'étude de l'opinion
américaine
la question économique non pas nationale
mais personnel et plus est un
déterminant du vote
quand on regarde les sondages sortie des
urnes quand on demande aux électeurs
en gros comment le pays fonctionne
comment le pays va
ils sont toujours très négatif quand on
leur demande comment eux ça va surtout
jour beaucoup plus positif et on
remarque que plus ils sont riches plus
on républicain et plus ça va plus il
vote et plus il vote républicain donc de
ce point de vue là on a une coupure du
pays qui a été assez nette au niveau de
la perception personnelle de l'économie
le pari de trump c'est que si pour les
américains personnellement ils ont un
boulot il ya de l'argent qui tombe à la
fin du mois un bon va ça va ils vont
peut-être donner le bénéfice du doute à
trump
ça reste très hypothétique mais nés dans
l'ordre du paris
jean baptiste du cac sur ce sujet oui
effectivement je crois que ce qui
caractérise donald trump s'est de tout
simplement de ne pas réfléchir la
réflexion c'est un temps comprend pour
adopter des décisions face à
circonstances données est en fait donald
trump ce qu'il fait classiquement c'est
que il y pense tous en fait il dit
exactement ce qui lui passe par la tête
et du cou en suivant la crise
eh bien il est en ligne vise la menace
comme d'ailleurs voulons pas pu le faire
au départ comme simple citoyen et puis
ensuite pour ne pas que ce contrôle y
ait effectivement la menace et présente
une certaine mesure
et puis si on accélère les choses l'inph
unedic finalement il faut que l'économie
reprenne
c'est un petit peu ce qui nous comme
citoyen nous a traversé l'esprit et les
responsables publics il va en plus de
réflexion prennent dans la décision d
il est ensuite facile de pouvoir prendre
quasiment au jour le jour les
déclarations de domaine troll pour les
confronter et dire que tout est
contradictoire milliers de certaine
manière
en fait on peut presque lui reprocher
c'est l'excès inverse de ce qui peut
être la leur communiquer le
politiquement chez nous puisque le
chenil justement la trop grande
réflexion frise avec la langue de bois
et un peu partout on a pu reprocher à
juste titre anodin moment de parfois
prendre des décisions qui n'étaient pas
claires au départ et qui méritait
désistement d'être précise là dans notre
quotidien l'attendait certaines réponses
donc je crois la évidemment l'excès
inverse des reproches qui nous met rien
d'étonnant donald trump fait ce qu'il
fallait tuer juste sa divine parce que
j'étais sapiens avait justement de
travailler sur la plage la prise orale
l'après corps 2008 le ce débat justement
sur la reprise de l'économie qui quand
même un blindé avait fer de lance de
teint il est quand même général est ce
que est ce que
je fais ma pole pour la santé et l'élan
de l'école bihan partout alors c'est
vrai causés aux états unis l'économie
occupe une place plus simple en france
après c'est vrai qu'il est vraiment
déstabilisé par ce qu'ils comptaient
faire campagne sur cette économie forte
et que là il se retrouve avec finalement
ces votants qui souvent ce sont des
personnes âgées qui sont en train de qui
sent qu'ils sont en train de mourir les
uns après les autres alors que lui ce
qui est testé tous les jours et surtout
la destruction économique aux états unis
elle était en train de se passer
essentiellement dans les swing states
les swing states ce sont les fameux
états en fait dont dépendent vraiment la
victoire c'est à dire qu'en vrai il ya
six états l'arizona le michigan
puisqu'on si la pennsylvanie genre de la
floride le rayo mais c'est dense et
swing states que la destruction
économique est la plus importante donc
il est vraiment déstabiliser moi j'étais
la première à dire il ya quelques
semaines que malheureusement trump
allait être réélu maintenant j'en suis
plus sûr du tout mais à côté de ça on
l'a fait on a là on à la banque centrale
américaine qui qui est en train
d'injecter des sommes délirantes aux
états unis donc là je suis ont promis
qu'à triompher puisque c'est en français
c'est 4000 milliards de dollars il faut
quand même savoir que les états unis le
dollar c'est c'est comme de l'or
finalement moi je pense qu'à une vraie
chance que les états unis ressortent
encore plus puissants de cette crise
comme après 2008 nous en france il nous
a fallu des années pour nous en remettre
aux états unis ça a été ça a été
beaucoup plus courts donc est ce que
finalement les américains vont pas être
les grands gagnants de cette crise est
possible ils vont peut-être aussi
finalement bouger les usines qui sont en
chine peut-être les mettre au mexique ce
qui va aussi résoudre le problème de
de l'immigration donc je pense que c'est
très difficile à dire je peux pas faire
de près de prévisions je pense que
personne ne peut le faire à ceux à ce
niveau mais il se passe aussi des il ya
des micros changements dans les swing
states par exemple il ya beaucoup de
californiens qui ont souhaité la
californie pour s'installer en arizona
et donc rien l'arizona est un des twins
states là il peut se passer quelque
chose d'intéressant c'est à dire que ça
peut vraiment retourné le vote en
arizona
oui le week end
alors ça c'est très intéressant parce
que ces deux questions sur lesquelles
j'ai travaillé dans des tailles l'aller
les swing states au fait qu'ils qui ont
été affectés par un haut niveau
économique c'est ceux de la rust belt et
ce2 autour des grands lacs et en fait il
y avait déjà une récession dans le
secteur manufacturier l'année dernière
et c'était un des grands paradoxes est
passé complètement inaperçu parce qu'on
se concentre uniquement sur les chiffres
du chômage qui sont extrêmement bon en
tout cas en apparence ils sont calculés
de manière très bon mais en tout cas
quand on les annonce ils ont l'air
extrêmement bon en revanche il ya une
récession dans le secteur manufacturier
dans les états qui ont fait l'élection
de donald trump en 2016 et donc la
question qui se posait déjà l'année
dernière avant l'épidémie
c'était de savoir si les électeurs là
bas dont l'usiné a fermé alors qu'on
leur dit mais le chômage est très peur
de quoi vous plaignez est ce que l ai
pas voté contre trump ou pas voter du
tout ce qui revient avec les contraintes
d'une certaine manière aussi ça c'était
déjà une question qui était entamée
avant les perturbations économiques du
coronavirus ensuite ce qu'on remarque
alors les gens qui se quittent la
californie en fait la majorité au texas
parce que il ne supporte plus dans un
état plutôt marxiste comme la californie
et ils veulent aller avec des gens qui
pensent comme eux et ils vont dans les
banlieue de dallas notamment s'il y
avait eu des gros gros échange et c'est
un des facteurs qui empêchent le texas
de basculer parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui viennent aussi des états du
nord est qui vont notamment à houston et
il ya en fait un mouvement en géorgie au
texas qui fait que c'est et action très
républicain sont en train de basculer
côté démocrate mais ça c'est quelque
chose qui était déjà en cours et
l'arizona c'était déjà en cours les
l'arizona et l'une sénatrices démocrates
qui étaient arrivés de
au moyen-âge en 2018 donc avant la crise
il faut faire bien attention à la
succession de changements en fête qui
avait lieu déjà et qui vont être soit
accentuée soient minimisés par la crise
mais qui était déjà en cours et l'autre
petits points je vous les souder
souligné qui est très différent de la
gestion en france c'est le fédéralisme
parce que quand on regarde les états
unis c'est 330 millions d'habitants donc
c'est pas du tout la même chose que
gérer un pays de 65 millions d'habitants
et c'est une organisation qui est très
différente
les gouverneurs des états notamment des
gros et avec de la population comme la
californie 1 40 million d'habitants ce
sixième économie mondiale l'état de new
york
la l'agglomération de new york c'est
plus 10 millions d'habitants
c'est pas la même chose que gérer le
nebraska où roulent de lower est donc ce
sont des espèces de 2 min président et
il ya une rivalité très très fort parce
que ce sont souvent les gros état d'état
démocrate et un énorme bras de fer qu'on
a vues entre les gouverneurs et run
étrave n'a pas la main sur un certain
nombre de décisions
le niveau fédéral que gertrude est un
niveau de surplomb et un niveau de de
logistique puisque de prise de décision
la réouverture des états ce n'est pas
lui qui fait comme en france où c'est
l'état très centralisé qui décide si on
ré ouvre et les préfets ont une certaine
marge de manoeuvre mais sont toujours en
gros sous les ordres du président c'est
ce qui explique peut-être d'ailleurs
qu'il a soutenu des manifestations on
dit pour le d'exactement dans un certain
état qui était quelqu'un qui m'est fait
est-ce que alors je pose la question par
les écoles certains gouverneurs et
certains maires des îles sont pas qu'ils
sont pas d'accord est-ce qu'il ya est ce
qu'on peut dire qu'il ne coupure
finalement république à démocrate sur
cette affaire c'est pas qu'il veut
répondre là dessus
oui internet florence nous donnera son
avis bien sûr moi c'est plus que je les
sentais même pas tant républicain
au crac qui qui se quittent pas de
compte mais pour moi c'est populis et
non populiste dans cette manière de
réfléchir la crise dans le sens où il y
a ceux qui ont envie d'être rassuré
d'entendre un discours comme celui de
donald trump et qui ont envie d'entendre
des éléments qui ne sont pas
nécessairement vérifier mais qui font
partie d'une espèce d'idéologie et il ya
ceux qui au contraire vont ce qu'on
appelle plutôt les strates intellectuels
vont avoir un besoin de s'en référer aux
informations officielles à des
politiciens qui eux auront une autre
manière de gouverner non pour moi c'est
plus des manières de gouvernance peut
décoder sensibilités qui s'expriment
dans ces moments là oui mais au parler
par exemple de la coupure de la france
s'enferre et rouges aux étals fille sur
deux couples robe bleue et rouge et bleu
étant les démocrates et les républicains
je range paris le wimpy je vous en prie
je pense qu'il ya peut-être une coupure
même au sein des républicains parce
qu'il doit y avoir un certain nombre de
républicains qui sont consternés par
l'attitude de trempe et je tends les
républicains qui sont très très tristes
c'est vraiment america first donc c'est
america faire c'était défense des
libertés et d'antan d un certain nombre
justement personnes qui étaient contre
finement qui disait mais nous les etats
unis sont un pays de liberté et
finalement c'est pas une liberté
collective c'est une liberté narrative
it bad et chacun fait ce qu'il veut ça
sont des républicains purs et durs mais
je ne suis pas certaine que une partie
des républicains ne soit pas très
satisfait un peu oui consterné par
l'attitude par l'attitude de preuves et
les démocrates je suis d'accord avec
charlène sont simplement des gens pour
un peu plus de distance et qui vont
chercher l'information ailleurs que qu'à
la maison blanche
la vanille oui je suis un peu étonné
comme l'impression qu'il ya une sorte de
deux dogmes clairement établies
notamment ce plateau que en dehors du
confinement n'y a pas de solution et que
le confinement c'est bien et qu'être
à voir juste l'idée de dire que confiné
n'est peut-être pas la meilleure chose à
faire
on est immédiatement traité de crétin de
trump heist ou deux a un peu curieux je
veux dire trump a bien évidemment gérer
la crise de façon un peu étonnante mais
voilà qui qui peut se permettre de dire
là aujourd'hui confinée c'est génial on
voit par exemple au pakistan des des
millions de pakistanais qui ont dix
roues et pourtant on peut pas parler de
deux pays très ouvert et dans cette
dictature despatis temps n'est-il pas le
courage de dire le confinement on s'en
fout on préfère prendre le risque de
mourir du de l'aco vide que de mourir de
faim deux peut avoir de boulot c'est
aussi quelque chose à prendre en compte
alors est ce que est ce que l'on est
complètement crétin quand on soutient
cette position
voilà en tout cas on n'ose en parler
pense que de le débat se côtoient entre
les gens intelligents qui serait là en
train de dire mais nous on est contre
tremblay puis les débats
c'est peut-être un peu plus compliqué
que ça c'est l'impression jean-charles
je suis remplaçant je n'ai pas dit que
confinement était forcément la meilleure
des solutions tu parlais du côté un peu
girouette avec des affirmations qui se
succèdent et qui épuise cox délirante si
tu auras l'autre javel et les uv pour
avoir de la chaleur est tué à l'aco vide
c'est ça qui est quand même tout à fait
consternant
on attend avec le confinement va
peut-être arriver à tendre vers le r0
qui met la façon de sortir du bas sont
peut-être prochaines élections d'abord
est ce que il ya un risque que ces
élections des pas lieu se fit oumouri
honnête je suis d'accord sur le fait que
l'élection se déroulera début novembre
ça a priori de toute façon
constitutionnellement je pense qu'il
peut pas déplacer la date
donc ça c'est une première chose
la deuxième chose c'est que sophie en
reparlera tout à l'heure mais il ya eu
une mobilisation de la galaxie obama
mais surtout ce qui est intéressant sur
sur la façon de de voter on voit un
développement de ce qui revient au vote
par correspondance finalement qui est
déjà la norme dans cinq états le débat
du côté des républicains ces dira oui
mais ça c'est un complot des démocrates
pour gagner les élections parce que ça
fait gagner les les démocrates
en fait c'est pas vrai parce que un état
comme l'ugta qui est hyper républicain
vote par correspondance à 100%
pratiquement et ça reste un hyper
république a donc yade il ya plusieurs
études de sciences politiques qui sont
attaqués à cette question la voir s'il y
avait un billet partisans dans le vote
par correspondance et en fait non pas
faire ça fait augmenter la participation
mais de manière équitable pour les deux
parties donc il n'y a pas de
manipulation des démocrates comme trump
et un certain nombre de républicains le
disent quand on développe le vote par
correspondance
évidemment c'est un moyen beaucoup plus
simple et sûre de ne pas faire voter les
gens en chair et en os c'est à dire de
les exposer à une éventuelle deuxième
vague comme on a vu dans l'élection du
wisconsin ya quelques semaines où on
voyait les gens on va faire la queue à
un mètre de distance donc fait attendre
des heures dehors avec leurs masques
dire gentiment tout ça pour avoir pour
voter à la primaire démocrate donc le
vote par correspondance qui ait déjà été
acquis on sait comment ça marche on sait
comment faire alors ça coûte un peu cher
mais bon c'est le plus sûr pour garantir
une élection à date fixe dans des
conditions sanitaires optimales
donc ça c'est ce qui permettrait à
l'élection de se tenir sachant que le
vote anticipé était déjà assez
plébiscité de plus en plus plébiscité
dans l'est dans les cycles électoraux
précédent donc ça permet de ne pas avoir
tout le monde dans les bureaux de vote
le jour j mais mais mais il ya quand
même la question de la campagne il ya
quand même cette affaire des accusations
dont il est l'objet
il ya un peu son silence
présent du lac au vide
est ce que ça peut lui coûter moi je
pense que non alors déjà il est passé
s'ils ont su que ça parce qu'il
intervient quand même tous les jours
après c'est un monsieur qui à 78 ans il
faut vraiment pas dessus la trappe la
côte mais non moi je moi je pense que
voilà il ya en plus bon alors c'est pas
bien de dire ça mais entre quelqu'un qui
a violé 20 femmes et un autre qu'un
jeune a tripoté une bon s'il faut
choisir voilà le choix est vite fait je
passe sur soi très politiquement correct
ça non mais par contre baden baden et
adoré par les syndicats qui sont
extrêmement puissant dont les swing
states mais adoré il est vrai il est
très respecté en sort il est sympa il
est il est compétent il a c'est le digne
successeur d'obama il a eu la très
grande élégance de se retirer aux
dernières élections pour laisser hillary
clinton parce qu'à l'époque la
continuité c'était voilà on avait eu un
président noir américain
après on voulait une femme et il s'est
quand même
il s'est retiré c'est quelqu'un qui
s'est bien comportée donc là il revient
quelque part c'est son tour et donc moi
je pense qu'il a de je pense qu'il a de
vraies chances et encore une fois la la
mobilisation de la communauté obama qui
est énorme parce qu'en fait obama il
avait mis du monde un peu partout dans
tous les états unis et tous ces gens
sont en train de se mobiliser des gens
qui étaient venus qui était parti dans
le privé qui sont en train de revenir
pour bayonne mon frère est dans l'équipe
de baden en l'arizona et il a fait une
levée de fonds sur le ciel est coupée à
chaque fois qu'elle va nous révéler des
choses non simplement dire d'un mot que
le lombric l'a rappelé
constitutionnellement l'élection sera de
toute façon obligés de se tenir puisque
il ya une échéance à date fixe pour la
fin de mandat
de donaldson et donc fois la maison
blanche évident fois on ne vise pas des
lois des pays où la constitution mais
très bizarre et absolument anti
constitutionnelle en tout cas nord-est
américain
donc en tout cas on n'a pas de
possibilité pour le moment de penser à
un avenir moins un pour les élections
elle se tient oui même s'il y avait
juste un cadre d'événements
exceptionnels de guerre de 60 en plus
c'est quand même une élection donc non
la deuxième guerre mondiale voire un
article et eux n'ont jamais triste oui
alors effectivement au 21 janvier de dan
cron fait que doit doit partir ou doit
rester la constitution est très claire
sur sur ce point en revanche ce qui est
envisageable mais l'arbre en trouver un
scénario vraiment presque intime et est
envisageable qu'ils seraient de
l'impossibilité d'organiser des
élections et donc de jouer en fait par
le remplacement du président par le
président du sénat puis par le
désengagement de rock important sachant
que dans maintenant il ya les élections
intermédiaires qui interdit d'un millier
du congrès de sorte que les équilibres
pourrait bouger en tout cas la
constitution prévoit quand même un
système de remplacements successifs qui
peut jouer mais là en soirée ou qui
paraît impensable
dès lors que comme l'a rappelé
hurricanes dont le vote par
correspondance est tout à fait
envisageable
oui loric et il faut rappeler que ceux
des patrons ou le congrès qui décide
s'il y aura ou il y aura pas d élections
se sait dans les états les modalités et
la tenue et la date des élections c'est
au niveau des états pour les primaires
démocrates
or la primaire démocrate c'était soit
les états soit le parti démocrate qu'il
organisait là encore c'est encore autre
chose
mais la question de savoir si on
maintenait la date où si on repousse et
s'est décidé dans les états l'état de
new york a voulu supprimer son élection
et finalement une décision de justice
qui a dit que c'était pas possible de
supprimer une élection donc de toute
façon on ne pourra pas de on ne pourra
pas jouer beaucoup on n'a pas le temps
et a même un amendement constitutionnel
fois que les trois quarts des états
puissent se prononcer pour ça faudrait
qu'il y ait un référendum dans chaque
état et donc qu'ils votent donc on peut
pas essayer de jouer sur au vote où on
vote pas 11 ans voter les gens sur on
voit ton repas dans deux autres façons
ça c'est pas jouable du tout et on a
plein de modalités maintenant qu'ils
sont déjà éprouvées
ils permettent de voter sans s'exposer
et je rappelle qu'en 40 et en 44 ans 40
les états unis n'étaient pas en guerre
mans 44 états unis t en guerre les
élections se sont déroulées vous nous
parler de votre frère l'équipe de thomas
essaie de régler ma connexion ont fait
campagne pour joe biden en arizona est
il donc il faut les levées de fonds par
zoom
évidemment on ne peut pas se réunir en
ce moment et en une heure elle m'a
expliqué les quelques l'élection qui l'a
fait en une heure il avait quatre cent
mille euros cette semaine en une heure
de zoom
c'est quand même extraordinaire c'est
donc il ya un vrai oui voilà lien il ya
un engouement
après moi aussi ce que j'espère c'est
que si on se fie à l'histoire enfin
historiquement aucun président américain
n'a été réélu depuis 100 ans à par
calvin coolidge dans les deux ans qui
ont suivi une récession
donc bon si on se base sur wii les cages
à passer on va dire qu'il ya peu de vice
présidents ont été élus
c'est vrai on se sert du président quant
à lui non c'est assez rare à paris
la part de gauche prg ouais enfin il ya
quelques heures il est unique sonne
enfin la deuxième fois mais il y en a
froid de l'équipement que nous
semble-t-il avec le premier ministre
oui comme si tôt avec le premier
ministre seulement ouais une comparaison
est chez nous c'est les deux et quand
même
très peiné en 46 74 ans parce que 75 78
on explique ça le fait qu' il n'y a plus
des vieux qui soit l'idée des alpes a
pas d pad ebit devrait vieux quoi il
soit il soit candidat à la présidence
des états unis
les rolling stones qui sont nés en 42
ans 43 sortent encore de chansons c'est
vrai mais non mais est ce que ça veut
dire qu'il ya un désintérêt au fond des
jeunes pour la politique
quand on regarde que quand on regarde
les juste un petit point quand on
regarde l'étendue des candidats
démocrates à la primaire y en a plein
qui avait 40 ans et qu'elles voire 37
ans avec pete beach
c'est juste qu'ils sont pas allés au
bout l'âge médian de tous les candidats
les 28 candidats démocrates étaient
autour de 2 50 ans avec plein qui
étaient des quadras mais ils sont pas
les français tout aussi qu'il ya déjà
des données territoriales loris a
rappelé tout à l'heure et en processus
de désignation des candidats
c'est à dire que e on envisagerait mal
aux etats-unis 1-1 ou quelqu'un qui est
ma nouvelle au dernier moment une
campagne présidentielle ce n'est pas
possible il faut des attaches dans son
parti il faut des attaches dans les
états fédérés il faut des attaches
quelque part territoriales pour détenir
quelqu'un de probant dans une campagne
et donc du coup ça privilégie quand même
des politiciens d'expérience ou des
personnes qui ont des attaches même
économie ou même professionnel dans
certains états et je crois que c'est
notamment peut-être un des facteurs qui
peut expliquer le fait qu'on a affaire à
des personnels d'expérience ou non en
moyenne ce n'est pas l'âge qui est tout
donner pour les écoles et les jeunes
quand il est élu
il ya des clubs qui les guide et des
très jeunes il ya plein d'exemples de
contrôle de contre-exemple clinton était
gouverneur depuis 12 ans clinton était
gouverneur de l'arkansas depuis 12 ans
donc c'est à dire qu'ils avaient une
expérience de l'exécutif était assez
ancienne et c'était un cadre du parti
démocrate
mais s il n'y a pas tellement salle
florence est-ce qu'il ya pas quand même
dans une période un peu trouble est
comme ça le recours à une figure alors
dire ça j'ai trompé comme ça est-ce que
ça ça ne rassure pas les opinions je
suis un peu d'accord avec avec lorik il
y avait quand même une foultitude de
candidats jeunes et ils ont pas été
jusqu'au bout ils n'ont pas été choisis
l'ont pas été voulu parce
qu'effectivement vous le disiez tout à
l'heure
mais ce fils joe biden part et il est
très sympathique il est très avenant il
ay est rassurant après là je rentre à
ses plannings de course et je pense que
c'est c'est plus dû au hasard et la
personnalité mais effectivement il y
avait il y avait des candidats
démocrates qui étaient très jeunes
bon je dis ça reviendra il ya des
présidents jeunes vous disiez patrice il
y en aura d'autres après se cristalliser
sur l'âge c'est un peu comme nous en
france bon ben on a voté pour un petit
peu cadré 39 ans c'est très bien c'est à
dire que une prochaine fois on ne pourra
pas voter pour quelqu'un qui aurait
soixante dix huit ans parce qu'on se dit
rama peut-être que l'expérience de temps
en temps c'est sympa et que et que le
passé voilà que le nouveau monde sait
rien et que quelquefois un peu d'anciens
monde c'est pas forcément une horreur
absolue
cela dit on va réfléchir parce que vous
savez que l'une des raisons de la de la
candidature de mitterrand 90 qui
s'interrogeait sur son âge ça avait été
la victoire face à 982 reagan qui
l'avait incité à sidi après tout voci
reagan elles sont assez ténue mais aussi
moins représentées et peut-être que
voilà comment en france d'aider des gens
plus âgés vous pensé à devenir président
alors il ne s'en fait pas florent sur
cette question là je suis assez d'accord
avec jean chante je pense que
c'est patent peut-être la question de
l'âge mais la question de l'expérience
et de la confiance que les citoyens
peuvent avoir dans cette expérience ils
ont besoin de personne et petits mots
qui a déjà parcours politique et et puis
on a la mémoire courte en peut-être
vivre des problèmes qui que ces
personnes là ont pu rencontrer les son
plan politique ou économique ou social
mais néanmois cette expérience-là peut
donner confiance confiance aux électeurs
j'ai juste peut-être questions
d'actualité vous avez je sais pas si
vous avez vu la déclaration du président
de sanofi qui fait des recherches sur
les vaccins
et qui dit merci et jamais on trouve le
vaccin ça sera d'abord quand même la
preuve que les états unis comptent
encore sur une puissance ça sera d'abord
aux américains comptent donnera ce
vaccin est ce que ce outre et ça le djia
pas ce qu'il dit c'est tout c'est eux
qui ont investi plus simple dans la
recherche est ce qu'on trouve ça logique
est ce que la santé doit sortir de
l'économie de marché
il leur est pourtant c'est cette
question qui n'a fait qu'aider l'autre
solution parce que je sais pas en fait
ce que ça veut dire de privilégier les
états unis vais parce que bon les six
vaccins fringant vaccin il y aura il va
être produit et distribué oui on aurait
préféré que ce soit d'abord en france
mais pourquoi d'abord en france ou
pourquoi d'abord en belgique où pour que
l'avion se c'est sud sur le principe
comme ça 2h au nom on dit c est
scandaleux mais bien évidemment ça va
aller partout après donc oui c'est
peut-être une question de temps c'était
en tout cas une communication
désastreuse de sanofi nous le faisons
parce qu'ils sont annoncés çà c'est
absolument catastrophique c'est un
exemple chances 2-2 de communication
ratée et de france coll comment faire
détester une boîte entre mamadou bah je
pense que c'est le truc idéal mais sinon
après oui je sais je il va falloir voir
comment ça peut se traduire cette
préférence se disant américaine on verra
qui demande un peu si c'est
effectivement ça on peut que le déplorer
mais parce que ça nous jouer le marché
marché de la santé a toujours était
quand même très très surprenant très est
très attaché à la finance et à l'est
côté peace a toujours été comme ça des
scandales
il a en l'espèce c'est pas forcément
étonnant puisqu'il continue à faire
comme avant et à des états unis ayant
effectivement financiers bourse partie
des recherches
ces deux ans de temps et je pense
qu'effectivement il aurait pu ne pas
communiquer sur ce sujet je suis assez
d'accord avec jean charles mauviot monde
le vieux monde se poursuit en tout cas
l'argument l'argument français est
exactement le même canton quand on
demande en fait pourquoi s'est il y
avait hier nick shadow sur france info
ce matin qui parlait de cic et tout ça
c'est quoi c'est de l'investissement les
avec les américains ont mis de l'argent
et discours d'où les français ont mis de
l'argent public et 10 c'est pour nous
donc ça reste à la question de ce que la
priorité à celui qui met de l'argent sur
le projet d'ajouter s'il n'y a pas de
gouvernance mondiale de la santé
alors on a vu le gros dos et ms nous a
parfois il critiqué mais ça reste une
organisation supranationale qui fait
certaines communications par rapport à
une expertise ils ont sur le plan
médical mais la santé est une compétence
des états et en plus les fabricants de
ces éléments de santé qui sont les
médicaments les vaccins etc sont des
entreprises privées donc après peut-être
qu'il faudrait se reposer des questions
de ce qu'on va mettre en commun au
niveau de tous les états unis mais je
crois que dans ce cas il faudrait
repenser toute la structure de l'om s
est même penser aux moyens de
financement commun qui supposerait qu'on
passe vraiment dans un mouvement de très
beaux jeux tout ça est assez assez
contradictoire avec toute la
communication qui est fait sur la santé
est un bien commun parce que c'est
intéressant ce qui se passe aussi les
états unis
vous dites la santé cette politique
d'état mais aux états unis on voit des
fondations notamment écrit me qui était
très en amont au fond c'est ccc presque
c'est des fondateurs de google de faire
des dégâts femmes qui se préoccupe le
plus
ils font des fondations qui fondent et
qui met beaucoup d'argent mais justement
une privatisation de la politique de son
ennemi privatisation du financement en a
marre de cette politique de
communication c'est à dire que à partir
du moment où on essaye de mettre
l'accent sur numa et ça ça ça c'est un
nouveau droit des entreprises qui est en
train d'émerger qui existent dans le
monde en france aux états unis et qui
consiste à humaniser l'économie donc dès
lors on veut remettre de l'humain on
reparle de la santé on reparle de
l'adico des essais se font très bien les
gars fassent et qu'ils ont compris que
occuper le terrain économie en le disant
on a parlé communication de sanofi tout
à l'heure eh bien c'était quelque chose
qui leur avait posé aussi beaucoup de
désamour un peu la part des remettre
l'accent sur l'humain c'est avant tout
une question de communication et au
finish encore une question d'économie
oui mais c'est parce que c'est pas une
question de pouvoir est ce que je te
parler
les patrons des gaffes à n'ont pas
compris que le pouvoir de demain ça
serait ça serait subi qu'il posséderait
la santé peut-être l'allongement de la
vie et puisqu'il ya beaucoup de
recherches sur le transhumanisme star et
sophie peut-être le dessus non après moi
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que l'on
sait que les amazon ou google soit en
train de se positionner dans le secteur
de la santé les médicaments les
commandes de médicaments
et puis aussi sur l'assurance santé
j'avais eu une conversation avec pascal
démurger de la maif qui m'expliquait que
la manif était en train d'essayer de se
réinventer en prévision justement de
l'arrivée des gaffes à sur le secteur de
l'assurance de l'assurance santé donc on
va c'est un secteur qui va être
révolutionné dans les années à venir est
plutôt plus de monde je crois je pense
qu'elle karachi où on passe à autre
chose
pas son attention à la france alors
justement bon sermon délai quoi car
toujours cinq jours de déconfinement les
pièces d by ce qu'ils disent
on prend trop de risques et ceux qui
disent on prend trop de précaution le
débat entre le principe de précaution
forêt puis l'année des risques
nécessaires
quel est votre sentiment là-dessus très
honnêtement je pense que
les précautions c'est très bien avec la
maman lefranc sortir parce que c'est ce
qu'on sait tous et que on peut tous nous
laisser dans une boîte
pendant des années il est sûr qu'on ne
sera pas malade maintenant il est
évident quand on va ouvrir la boîte on
va tomber malade donc les gens qui
disent c'est trop tôt on l'a fait quinze
jours trop tôt ça n'aurait rien changé
dans quinze jours on aurait la même
situation cette fois on risque de
trouver il ya bien un moment il faut des
confiné et c'est extrêmement important
mais pas que pour l'économie pour
l'économie bien sûr mais aussi pour la
santé mentale des gens dont on devient
dingue à être confinés où on est
infantilisé chaque jour un petit peu
plus soit quand et puis des décisions
j'ai beau mois et que plutôt se soutenir
edouard philippe et emma kong
enfin je veux dire on se demande si là
ils sont pas en train de tomber sur la
tête en train de cette polémique sur les
plages en autorise les gens allaient
s'agglutiner dans les supermarchés on
les emmerde en disant que des palois
reposer une serviette sur une plage on
n'a pas le droit d'aller dans la forêt
on a le droit d'aller d'aller chez
auchan et carrefour mais on est vraiment
c'est des dingues avec qu'est ce qu'est
ce que les gens restent on a interdit
aux gens de faire du bateau qu'est ce
que kate ont risqué à faire du bateau
tout seul en pleine mer enfin tout ça et
est juste ridicule et ce bien que
l'opinion publique est absolument
terrorisée elle demande c'est un peu
l'un vertes de se le disait de ce que
dénonce et florence tout à l'heure c'est
qu'en france j'ai l'impression que moi
en ait connaissance plus on est
terrorisée par le parce cette maladie et
que l'on veut une surprotection de
l'état je suis troublé
j'ai mes étudiants qui ont tous entre 19
et 20 ans ils sont tous terrorisés par
le dé confinement et de ne sont pas
sortis lundi né mardi
il m'a dit ah non non nous on va rester
confiné le plus longtemps possible c'est
pas grave il faut rester chez nous et
c'est une génération qui ça m'effraie un
petit peu ils sont tout à fait
sympathique et complétant par ailleurs
mais c'est un peu effrayant on a
l'impression que de toute notion de
risque a disparu de leur mentalité
telles que ils sont les bienvenus non
mais c'est où qu'on peut pas sortir
c'est trop terrible etc il faut qu'on
nous protège il peut se protéger etc
c'est absolument ahurissant enfin veut
de penser ça à 20 ans on a l'impression
que c'est d'aider les vieux comme vous
disiez patrice depuis 75 ans envie de
sortir
les jeux de 20 ans convient de rester
confinés et abracadabrantesque largement
dépendre des étudiants parce que je n'ai
pas dû avoir à lui même que jean-charles
mais une semaine avant le confinant et
il avait le sentiment que c'est l'une
des fois il fallait leur expliquer qu'on
était obligé par notre université de se
mettre à un mètre de haut et ont été
regardés comme des vieilles choses
qu'ils craignaient pour leur santé donc
celle d'une sortie mans d'être à la
retraite à ces jeunes nous aurait coûté
remarquer légal
on avait conversé un peu avant cette
démission
il y avait des choses un peu bizarre par
exemple c'est vrai qu'on les a fixés des
écoles où personne n'a mis les pieds
depuis deux mois sur de protection qui
est parfois bizarre c'est à dire que
enfin il ya une telle peur de la peur
aussi que on arrive à des comportements
qui sont complètement ubuesque
l'histoire j'ai entendu un chef
d'établissement sur une radio publique
il parlait justement de désinfecter
intégralement une école qui avait pas
été ouverte depuis deux mois je suis
tombé de ma chaise
parce que ça ça n'a aucun sens agir pour
que a invoqué le bon sens c'est
populiste et d'extrême droite mais enfin
là n'importe qui d'un peu bien dans sa
tête c'est que on nous a répété que le
virus ne survivait et que quatre jours
tout au plus sur certaines surfaces et
24 heures sur d'autres
donc là c'était vraiment mais vraiment
du délire total alors que quand on voir
mes parents m'ont diable on a vu ça à la
télé c'est terrifiant il favorise t truc
ils seront scaphandre entier donc là
quand enfin quand on pense aux risques
d'allergies et aux risques qu'ils vont
survenir 2 ce comportement qui sont bien
plus importants que les risques si on si
on fait par un petit coup de balai et
puis c'est tout c'est dingue mais sur
l'est sur les plages
alors j'avais un collègue à saint
quentin jean didier urbain qui est qu'à
quitter l'université qui est spécialiste
du tourisme et notamment des plages et
ils auraient pu nous dire à quel point
les plages sont un enjeu politique
les plages c'est la liberté et yahia
un enjeu sur la gestion de la liberté en
attendant la dans la gestion de cette
crise à la française c'est à dire la
serva acratie où on rivalise à chebba si
vous avez entendu le préfet de loire
atlantique hier m'enfin il y avait et il
y avait 25 pages de condition qu'on vous
dira n'allait pas sur les plages donc il
ya un enjeu qui n'est pas un enjeu de
santé publique il ya un enjeu de presque
philosophique sur la plage la mer et la
l'évasion et la liberté
c'est vrai que quand on veut réaliser
j'avais entendu il y avait une dame qui
était à nice sur la plage tout seul sur
sa serviette attisé massage jeanmaire de
qui là je vais contaminée qui lie à
personne la caméra c'est le taux il y
avait personne
et ben non c'était interdit pourquoi
parce que c'est interdit donc contaminer
les bureaux et les crabes france
oui alors pour répondre en partie à ces
exigences qui nous ont été imposées et
notamment comprendre l'exemple de ce
chef d'établissement qui a fait beaucoup
de zèle
c'est aussi parce qu'il ya une
responsabilité qu'ils portent aux chefs
d'établissements comme les chefs
d'entreprise sur une responsabilité qui
peut être et de responsabilité pénale
donc là qu'ils ont vraiment peur aussi
retrouver avec des problématiques
voilà par exemple quand on voit des
usines de renault qui a été la cgt a
poursuivi la direction de renault parce
qu'il y avait un vice de forme sur la
consultation des représentants du
personnel notamment voilà sur cette
thématique
il en place des mesures sanitaires le
jugent de manière complètement
ahurissante a fait fermer l usine
mais à la date tombe sur des choses qui
sont acquis sont très bon car d'ailleurs
la cgt était dénoncée comme les autres
syndicats en disant c'est un scandale de
voir
ok ce procès mais je pense que notamment
sur les chefs d'établissement sur les
maires qu'ils ont pas renoncé c'est bien
pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il est nul
ordonnance qu'il a essayé d'atténuer
cette responsabilité et notamment des
maires soit ils se retrouvent avec des
responsabilités pénales
en tout cas ce proxy qui pèse beaucoup
dans la lah procédé des chefs
d'entreprises et d'établissements
justement parce que notre dame en fait
très peu de temps deux minutes et je
vais demander aux uns aux autres et vous
pensez ou font que on parle de la peur
il ya la distanciation le fait que voilà
on se touche moins qu'on soit la
distance des déserts les autres à ce que
vous pensez que au fond cette crise val
considérablement changer d'air et les
rapports sociaux d'autres rapports
presque au monde justement avec cette
peur peut-être jean baptiste du père moi
je ne crois pas je crois qu'on change
parce que on a vécu quelque chose
d'extrêmement grave
passée la rupture amoureuse
la paire d'un envoi qui fait que soit on
descend soit on remonte mais là je crois
que face à cette situation de crise
sanitaire en faisant finalement qu'à
parce qu'ils sont directement impactés
par la maladie je crois que c'est
quelque chose qu'on voit de loin moi je
crois que ce qui nous touche pas
immédiatement qu'on ne sait pas
exactement réagir alors bien sûr à chaud
sur le moment et chacun y va de son
commentaire pour dire quel est l'avenir
politique qu'il ait fallu prendre
et quelle solution est la meilleure mais
je ne crois pas qu'il y aura pas
d'impact direct c'est un petit peu comme
et finalement les problèmes
environnementaux c'est quelque chose
pour le calcul monde est d'accord pour
dire qu'il ya un problème et qu'il faut
agir mais comme personne
on est toujours directement adapté on
n'agit pas moi j'ai un peu le sentiment
que l'on va on va revenir à au monde
d'avant pour le monde d'après c'est ce
que je crois qu'en tout cas beaucoup de
français ils veulent c'est que ça
devienne un mauvais souvenir
et ce jour de plus jamais ça on l'a vécu
après la crise de 2008 on a vécu après
les attentats terroristes et on s'est
dit qu'on allait changer notre société
et au finish on n'est jamais aussi
heureux que quand on a de chances à être
toutefois aussi que ça fait partie un
petit peu de l'esprit français est il au
moins je suis la première à penser que
d'ici quelques temps on pourra tout se
faire la bise et ça sera échangeable
ben oui oui moi je suis assez d'accord
avec charlène et jean baptiste
après je pense qu il reconnu une
certaine prise de conscience notamment
sur l'écologie de la nature et une
certaine attention qu'on pourra porter à
certains certains comportements après
c'est ça c'est la vision un peu
optimiste des choses quand je vois une
queue de 300 mètres de long devant chez
zara
mais à l'ouverture de la boutique je me
dis ben voilà le monde le groupe
d'avants mais mon caddie 0 des ventes
d'avant voilà pompiers c'est ce qui
s'est passé exactement le l'exemple que
je voulais donner sur assure sarah sur
des centres commerciaux en fait tout le
monde s'est précipité
c'est quand même étonnant d'avoir comme
première un premier point en contraints
d'aller chez a racheté reprennent pour
l'économie
à ce poids là est ce que j'ai pu
observer pendant le pendant le
confinement c'est que quand on sortait
même avec un masque et même si on était
à deux mètres de distance tout le monde
se disait bonjour je sais pas si c'est
comme ça pareil mais en tout cas en
province
beaulieu en tout cas tout le monde se
dit bonjour en ce moment là qu'on ne
faisait pas bon et d'une espèce de
reconnaissance au départ on avait la
peur de l'autre et donc on part il a dit
bonjour
parce qu'on se reconnaît pas quand on se
dit bonjour on sait jamais qui derrière
dans le dos étant dit bonjour à tout le
monde est le leur et qu'elles n'ont pas
deux choses aussi les gens se lâchent un
peu plus les mains ce sera déjà une
grosse victoire parce que ça c'était pas
gagné et je pense que il faut distinguer
ce qui va changer au niveau des gens est
ce qui va changer au niveau des des
gouvernants parce que si les équipes
changent pas c'est à dire les
représentants et puis les équipes qui a
derrière de toute façon rien ne changera
et ce film al green
moi tout ce que j'espère c'est bon et
déjà le lavage des mains est
effectivement serait pas mal mais
également un petit peu plus de respect
envers les autres parce que c'est vrai
que
on à paris en tout cas on voit des
comportements très limites dans la rue
des gens qui vous frôlent qui vous tous
encore dessus alors qu'on est quand même
maintenant sensibiliser donc on peut
peut être espérer que comme en asie
quand les gens ont des symptômes métro
un max ce sera déjà pas mal donc pour
stopper le télétravail
personne n'est pour la phrase de
wahlberg qui dit le monde d'après ça
serait moments d'avant mais en pire
oui le plus optimiste copie merci merci
à tous et merci à tous et merci pour
votre éclairage justement sur les états
unis s'étaient c'était passionnant et
après les cours pour un nouveau numéro
deux heures
[Musique]